we also noticed that the dogmatic
structure of the church still left still
left the door open for the divine
individual it's like you don't get a
hierarchy without getting a tyranny
along with it you know but but there's a
hell of a difference between the 30 or
so countries in the world where anyone
with any sense would want to live and
the other hundred and fifty where that
are basically run by barbaric thugs and
it's important to keep the distinction
between those two things in dying it's
like yeah we've got some things that we
should put together and clean up and you
know people are discriminated against
for unfair reasons and that's to
everyone's detriment obviously but it's
a multivariate problem and the the the
the the positioning of someone in a
hierarchy of competence is in part due
to their
what would you say to the historical
context within which that hierarchy has
emerged but to say it's all a
consequence of that is part of what I
regard as the radical leftist war on the
idea of competence itself because I
actually think that's the fundamental
narrative driving the real radical
leftists is that they hate the idea of
competence itself it's deeper than
Orwell's comment George Orwell's comment
in in Road to Wigan Pier where he said
well the problem with middle-class
british socialists is that they don't
like the poor they just hate the rich
just like dad on man vicious vicious
diagnosis it's worse than that is that
is that the the radical leftists don't
like the oppressed they just hate the
competent I really believe that I think
it's I think it's unbelievably
pathological and dangerous it is so the
more nuanced conversations like these
rather than binary yes-or-no sort of
reductionist conversations around
complex topics like a competence
hierarchy that surface to fruition in
the media sphere I think over time we
will get to a point where more and more
people have deeply complex and nuanced
conversation of